[inaudible]
[inaudible],
stern and justice and people were behaving
like the old goods was little ball
was misled by none little bar.
This is what he's saying.
Me and you guy were
going to make some cash,
robbing new foods.
Then Megan the Dash,
the day of the child money came with ease.
Rap had a disease.
He,
Robert Nava Amnon,
her sister and a brother tried
to rob a man was DJ on the cover.
The cop grabbed his arm and Dagney
ran and keeps it keeps still ball.
There's no need for static,
I'm assuming that spell
it gave him a slab.
Literally no little ball.
A strap pulled out his gun said,
why you hit me bill head
straight for the cow.
Kimmy cop gets scared.
She starts to figure out
is if I pull this trigger.
So gastric band around black cow radios
and when another medi cal ran by tree
there is solid since chapel.
The head shot back but he messed up.
Look rounded.
Firm expectation.
He decided he'd head full
the subway station but she
was coming so when may left
he was running top speed
and was out of breath.
Knocked the no man down,
slowly killed him.
The meters lose weight.
An abandoned building ran upstairs to,
that's how I flow booting up the door.
And guess what?
It saw Dave,
the dope fiend shooting dope.
You don't know the meaning of water.
No soup.
He said,
I need bullets.
Hurry,
go run.
Duping brought back to spank and shy
when outside dude was [inaudible] Luke's
who dip to car wasn't stolen,
not near three,
crashed into extreme.
He University [inaudible] Ratatat tatted
and now the cat scan Skadden rent out
of bullet,
but it's still has daddy
ran a brain and down
gum through caps,
back off or hunting his
dad deep in his heart.
He knew it was wrong.
So let let it go and he starts to move on.
Siren sounded seem to sit down and out.
The little boy got surrounded,
he dropped his gun.
So when,
and this is where to in his story,
he was only 19 and a madman.
Stream pantsuit kid to
still hear him scream.
The same font is don't you Dan lab,
just another case bout around bad
straight and now will your soul gets ass.
Good night shout.
Oh yeah.
That was beautiful.
That reminded me of the
Trayvon Martin case.
Man.